if you want to learn about a business
learn about an industry go get some
experience by working for somebody who
you respect in the business and they'll
teach you the ropes and minimize your
chances of failing when you start your
own business hi I'm Evan Carmichael I
believe that hungry entrepreneurs
deserve help and today Mason a question
from a YouTube viewer evil Alice
productions thank you for writing in
love your youtube guys wrote in saying
hi Evan can you please make a video
where you tell how to start a car
dealership business would be really
happy when you make a video or you apply
to me I graduated high school don't have
a job right now I'm pretty young have a
lot to learn I want to start car
dealership because I'm interested in
cars since I was two and I want to make
a company that's connected to cars
Thanks for writing in evil Alice evil
Alice productions great question I like
that you're starting off from a place of
passion it's something I really believe
in you have to start a business around
something that you're passionate about
that gives you the greatest chance of
success you're more likely to follow
through to keep going if you love your
business instead of just trying to make
money so the fact that you love cars
since you were two gives you a great
advantage to be able to have success in
the car business now you're young and
that's great I mean when I had my first
business I was young too so there's
nothing against young people what would
really help you in this stage of life is
to get some experience in the business
if you want to start a car dealership go
work for car dealership look at the most
successful car dealership in your area
and offer to work for them even for free
to get started you are there to learn
because if you try to start a car
dealership now it's going to cost a lot
of money it's going to cost a lot of
time you're going to have to take out
loans either yourself or through friends
and family and your chances of success
are really low because you don't know
what you're doing yet and you're going
to lose all that money I don't want that
for you to give yourself the best chance
of success go work for someone who's
already done this and who's doing really
well don't just go work at some crappy
car dealership find the best one the one
that you emulate the one you want to
look up to the one who's killing it
right now go work for them learn the
ropes try to do as much as you can in
the dealership get exposed to as many
opportunities and jobs as you can in
that dealership get to know the owner
make connection
learn the ropes you are getting paid to
learn how to start your own business
instead of having a hired consultants to
help you launch you are getting paid and
to make mistakes while getting paid
you're going to learn how to run a
business how to get it started up how to
hire people how to bring in new cars how
to promote them all the ins and outs of
that business you're going to learn and
get paid to do it now you have to go
work for them for 10 years and get
locked into this company if your
ambitions will start the business sooner
than you can but you least have the
knowledge and the connections to be able
to launch this new company that's your
best bet the other thing is going to
tell you is if you really want to start
a car dealership or not I know you love
cars that's awesome you're going to
start a business is connected to cars
that's great but it may not be a
dealership and the only way you're going
to know is either to launch your own or
to start working for somebody else and
if you're working on the job at a car
dealership and you find out like this is
this isn't what I thought it was you
know sometimes you internet companies
and you realize wow this field is not
what I really wanted to do that just
saved you huge dollars instead of
starting a dealer [ __ ] up delish it up
and then realizing that you know this
isn't the business you want to be in you
do it on somebody else's dime and if
it's not a car dealership maybe it's
something else maybe you're building
cars maybe you're racing cars I don't
know its cars I know you love cars
that's great you got to find out what
the businesses and the best way is to
take on little opportunities working at
different companies the best in their
field learn from them secrets for you
learn the ropes and when you start your
business you'll have the best chance of
success good luck and thanks for
watching for everybody who is watching
this video please give it a thumbs up
below makes want to do more for you and
I love to hear we get to think about
this video or if you have a question for
your own business please leave in the
comments below I really do read those
every day while I'm eating my breakfast
it makes me smile because I see the
great comments coming in so even just
saying hey Ivan love the video that's
great so thank you and I'll see you on
the next episode
you